um
by taking it off
uh
i'll use this
i want to open up the work session in an
executive session this morning
and this morning we have some
replacements
for
legislators the replacements are
but tom lockman mary representative
mary jane wallner
and from mary griffin
representative len
turcotte
did i say that correctly
i guess so
and for representative bob elliott
carol mcguire
we have a total of 18 bills
we want to
discuss today
we've had caucuses both in both parties
reviewing all bills
and i've talked with the
ranking
member from the other party
see where we stand it looks like that
we're consistent on about nine bills
that we could exact today
so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to take
and do the exacting on these nine bills
right away
and then
we will discuss the other bill's
numerical order
the first bill i want to exact i'm going
to hold
for a while because
i received an email this morning
from the dra
and the ra asked if it possibly could be
amended to
make one more change which is a simple
change
it doesn't affect the law all of the
effects
is the cost of mailing
it's considerable savings if we do this
so representative romney
races enough to run over
get the amendment done and it should be
brought down to us soon so i'm going to
delay
uh the executive session on house bills
1063. and go to
house bill
permitting voluntary donations to
municipalities or the state to fund
certain projects
or to reduce taxation
representing your lee
representative moves itl on
and before you see seconded by
representative
too many folders
the second by representing army
almy
representing early
thank you mr chair uh this is a
well-intentioned bill uh seeking to
allow voluntary
donations however it is a bit redundant
in that
such donations
are
already allowed
in addition the wording to the bill
seems to converse commercialize such
donations
and may even leave the door open for
authorizing
entities to ethics charges of favoritism
as a
result of a donation being made in this
fashion
one should also note that some agencies
including the housing finance authority
and new hampshire libraries under their
specific rsas are already authorized to
accept donations
in a
m-a-n-a-t-t
memo
found in the municipal association of
the
donations of some types in medical
fields may complicate
medicare and medicaid
regulations so that's a consideration
that this bill needs to take under
consideration
in addition under rsa 3119 i a political
subdivision may accept donations for a
project this particular bill doesn't
meet the requirements of that piece of
legislation because it doesn't designate
as to what type of
donation is being made and the supreme
court has laid out what the donations
have to be and you can also find that in
a 2013 municipal association uh white
paper
therefore uh this bill should is
recommended in expedient to legislate at
this time
any further discussion on
the motion to itl on house bill 1189
in no further discussion i'll ask the
court to call the role
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting with representative patrick
abrami yes
yes
thank you
subbing for mary griffin representative
turcotte
yes
representative hollery yes
subbing for doucet is representative
losales
yes
representative lang
the clerk votes no on the itl motion
representative mcguire subbing for
representative elliott
representative genigean
representative nunes yes representative
spillsbury
representative tudor yes
representative
representative ames
representative southworth
is not present representative malloy yes
representative schomburg
representative tucker yes representative
gomarlo
subbing for representative laughman is
representative walner
yes
representative gorg
not voting representative hacken
phillips yes
representative murphy yes chairman major
yes
mr chair of the vote is 24. there was
one scaffold who voted no and two were
not voting so 21-1
the vote been 20 to one
the motion of itl passes
without objection it will go on consent
any objection
and appear on the consent calendar
he's not objecting
the next
is house bill 1204
1204-fn-a-local
an act reducing the rate of the meals
and rooms tax and increasing the revenue
sharing of meals and rooms tax revenue
with municipalities
representative romney
i move itl on house bill 1204
oh i'm sorry
thank you
i moved interim study on house bill
1204.
do we have a second
second
by lang i mean representation
sorry about that
representative romney you want to speak
to your motion
yes what this bill does is it reduces
the uh meals and rooms tax from 8.5
percent down to 7.9 percent
but at the same time it increases the
percentage
that goes to the municipalities from 30
to 40 percent
now in the last budget
uh in hb2
they we we raised we just raised the
what went to the municipalities to 30
percent
from what was running
in the low 20s for the last couple of
budgets
so i i think i think with that
i i don't see
uh us
really moving with this and that we
should continue to study this
as a committee thank you mr chair
any further discussion on house bill
representative
sorry
thank you mr chair i think it would be
good on
in
the blurbs to where it's relevant to
mention that we are concerned
with the surplus
that's a good suggestion thank
you any further discussion
send none and i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the vote
thank you mr chair we'll begin the
voting with representative abrami
representative turcotte yes
representative ory yes
representative lisales
yes
representative lang
yes the clerk votes yes
representative mcguire
representative genigean
representative nunes yes representative
spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes
representative almi
representative ames
representative southworth is not voting
representative malloy yes
representative schomburg
there are too many mics on you can only
have three on at a time
yes there we go
mr clerk there we are thank you i've
recorded your vote as yes
thank you sir representative tucker yes
representative gomarlo
representative walner
yes
representative gorg is not voting
representative hacken phillips yes
representative murphy
chairman major
yes
the vote been 21 to nothing
for the motion
of interim study passes
the last one was 20 to 1.
so without objection go on consent
it will go on consent
the next will be house bill 1228
an act relative to the recommendation
of the joint committee on dedicated
funds
representative bernstein
i would like to motion
otp
on hb 1228
you have a second
representing element
let's speak to the emotion
thank you
this bill repeals various inactive
dedicated funds
deposits any remaining funds of repealed
dedicated funds into active funds
and revises the reporting requirements
for certain dedicated funds hb 1228 was
requested by the joint committee on
dedicated funds which was established to
review the finances and purpose of all
dedicated funds on a five-year rotating
basis and recommend continuance
amendment or repeal of relevant
provisions the joint committee on
dedicated funds sought and received
significant input from the affected
agencies in order to complete their
annual report which was the basis for
this bill so i encourage you all to
support the good work of the committee
and support the otp motion
thank you
further discussion on house bill 1228
san nuno asked the clerk to call the
vote
begin the voting with representative
patrick abrami yes
representative turcotte yes
representative
hollery
yes
representative lisales
yes representative lang
yes the clerk votes yes representative
mcguire
yes representative
representative nunez yes representative
spillsbury
representative tudor
representative almi
yes representative ames
yes representative southworth
is it not voting representative malloy
yes representative schomburg
yes representative tucker
representative gomarlo yes
representative wallner
gorg is not voting
representative hacken phillips yes
representative murphy yes the
representative major yes
vote is 21 to nothing
the vote been 21 to nothing on the
motion about to pass
it passes
and without objection
we'll put it on the
don't consent any objection so house
bill 20 12 28 will go on consent
the next bill is house bill 1338
an act establishing a committee to study
imposing attacks on manufacturing
based on the cost to dispose of
single-use products
and product packaging materials
representative elni
thank you mr chairman i'd like to move
on itl
on this bill and speak to my motion
representative elmi moves itl on 1338
second second by representing early
representative
thank you on
i've had considerable conversation with
the
sponsor about this
on and with the
the ranking member in the
environment and agriculture committee
and
they have
we've determined that environment and
agriculture has and is working in a
bipartisan fashion on a major
landfill study bill which includes the
concept of
on
producer
uh i keep forgetting what that that
stands for but producer extended
responsibility on
that is that the people who produce
things that
on
are difficult to dispose of
in landfills or recycling or whichever
on
should be including in the cost of their
materials the
the um
the cost of disposal
and that uh
that
bill over in environment and agriculture
is going to is being stripped of all
reference to
the uh how the costs would be paid
and talking only about the technical
aspects
of how this would be done
and how to reduce the
the bulk going into our landfills so
that we will still have landfills in
10-15 years in this state
and
they they are open to taking anything
from this bill that is new to
to the
producer extended responsibility concept
and including it as part of the study
the sponsor has
done some interesting work on
single-use products and and prop product
packaging
use and
is
willing as i understand it to
collaborate
with ena on their work
and
for that reason
and because
this also technically
would present a lot of issues
if we were to consider it in this
committee before the work has been done
by ena on
on should be recommended itl for this
term
representative representative
has an addition
okay thank you representative
further discussion representing early
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank the
ranking member for
her comments regarding this bill
i would hope that the blurb would
include that this particular bill
without that basic information
was totally unworkable
and
the
the bill
didn't make a distinction between
component elements of a manufactured
project and
that's something
you're kind of signaling to edie and
a that
that particular area needs to be looked
at as well so that
if
my fountain pen has one piece that's not
recyclable
does that get counted or not counted
that there's just a lot of stuff that
needs to be dealt with on that thank you
mr chairman
thank you represent any further
discussion
it's in none then i'll ask the court to
call the vote
of itl on house bill 1338.
thank you mr chair we will begin voting
with representative abrami yes
turcotte yes
yes los alas
yes lange
yes
berstein votes yes
maguire
yes nunes
yes
ames
southworth is not voting malloy yes
representative thomas schamberg yes mr
court
representative tucker
go marlow
yes
walner yes
gorg is not voting hacking phillips yes
murphy yes chairman major yes
the vote been 21-0
the motion of itl passes
without objection it will go on consent
it will go on consent
the next bill
is house bill 1407-fn
an act including the promotion of
affordable housing
under the land and community heritage
investment program
representative milo
thank you mr chair
while we all recognize the crisis in new
hampshire with our housing
l-chip is not the avenue i'm gonna make
the motion
oh i'm sorry
i'm so sorry
um i make the motion to itl
representative gamalo makes the motion
of itl
and representative spellsbury makes
seconds that motion
representative
sorry about that
while we recognize that the housing
crisis in new hampshire
is great um we don't i don't believe
l-chip is the appropriate avenue for a
remedy
and nor should we take dollars from the
general fund
the amendment offered
would be best discussed with all all the
stakeholders
and they can bring forth legislation
next year with any
ideas and recommendations that came from
that
thank you
thank you representative
any other
comments
saying none and i'll ask clark to call
the vote on itl on house bill 1407.
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting with representative abrami yes
turcotte yes owen
yes les alex
yes
lange
yes bernstein votes yes
mcguire
yes
spillsbury
tudor yes
almi
yes
ames
southworth is not voting malloy
schomburg
tucker yes
go marlow yes
walnut
gorg is now voting hacking phillips yes
murphy
yes chairman major yes
the vote been 21 to nothing on the
motion of itl on household 1407 it
passes
without objection you go on consent and
i see no objection so it will appear on
the consent calendar
the next bell is
there's house bill 1500
fn a and act reducing the rate of the
communication service tax and repealing
the tax in 2025.
represented
tunisian thank you mr chairman i move
interim study
representative
moves into a study seconded by
i'll second that
representative
representation you want to speak to your
motion
yes very very simply
this bill needs more study
and
primarily we need more info and we need
to study the applicability
of this
of this bill and tax
as as we've got a changing environment
landlines cell phones
and
i just feel like we need more study on
this so
i think interim study is the appropriate
venue at this point
thank you representative
any further discussion
london i'll ask the court to call the
vote uh
interim study on house bill 1500.
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting with representative abrami yes
turcotte yes
yes
alice yes lang yes the clerk votes yes
maguire yes
genigion
nunez yes
spillsbury
tudor yes army
yes
ames
southworth is a no vote malloy i'm sorry
it's a
no
correct
malloy yes
schaumburg representative schamberg vote
yes thank you
representative tucker
go marlow yes
walner yes
gorg is not voting
hacking phillips yes
murphy yes
chairman major
yes
the vote being 21-0
on the motion of interim study
that passes on house bill 1500
without objection to go on consent
i see no objection
mr chairman yes could i just mention on
representative southworth and i believe
representative gorg
are not going to be able to
vote during this whole
year
due to
on
the commitments that they have outside
the legislature that make it impossible
to expose themselves to the environment
so
on we are not
bringing in substitutes
uh
in general
unless we think that there is are going
to be votes that we need to
to uh affirm our entire presence for
thank you
thank you representative
elmi i hope and pray that this whole
pandemic thing
disappears very soon
it's not nice
the next bill
is house bill 1525
house bill 1525-fn-a
an act establishing a county nursing
home capital reserve fund
representative romney uh thank you mr
chair i make the motion of interim study
on this bill
senator romney makes the motion of
interim study seconded by
representative schamberg representative
representative
thank you mr chair uh yes well the bill
does set up a uh
capital reserve fund for our county home
nursing homes uh seating it with 25 000
this year
million i'm sorry thank you a couple
more zeros i put my glasses back on
and then
up to additional 15 million each year
but never to exceed 30 million in the
fund
the the reality is that everybody who
testified on this bill was from sullivan
county and i will i will recognize that
sullivan county does have a problem in
that
they
their nursing home needs to be replaced
but the price tag has now gone up to 54
million dollars for the county to do so
uh
but the problem we got is that
all counties have the same issue
the thing one thing that's unique about
sullivan county is that
the highest percentage
of nursing home patients 56
of any county that is treated they don't
have many independent nursing home beds
in
you know independent
nursing homes
and so there's a higher reliance on on
their nursing home
for
for this the problem with the bill
though is
once we get into this terrain of of
doing a bell
there really was no other testimony from
any other county any other county
executive saying let's do this bill it
was everybody who testified was sullivan
county
i think long-term
we're going to inter-study it
but my suggestion and i've made this uh
already is that they just look for an
appropriation
let's not go through
developing this capital fund but let's
go through and just try to get an
appropriation
above and beyond the budget to so to
solve their problem
but for now we're just going to i'm
suggesting that we interim study this
uh to keep it alive but uh but that that
would be my suggestion so
so again i think it'll be
again no other counties asking for this
uh the
the municipal association well they
don't really represent the county so
no one else really came in other than
sullivan county people to testify on
this bill so
that that's
with that i think we hopefully we can
study this thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman
on
i believe that the head of the
county
chairs
delegation chairs
who is from my county
on
sent a letter in about this
in my opinion this is a major problem
for two counties and i'm not quite sure
why
coast didn't
send anybody in but they have actually a
worse monetary problem on this
there are two counties that are at the
very bottom of the list in
the amount of real estate valuation per
capita
and that is
koas first and sullivan second
and
they really have serious problems with
being able to rebuild their nursing
homes especially with the increase in
federal regulations on what has to go
into that
on however we are in a major
we have major question marks about
what our revenues are going to look like
by the end of this fiscal year never
mind the next couple
and this is would be a huge amount of
spending on
and
has a great deal of
vagueness about how much money could go
to different counties for what
and we do know that a number of the
counties that are better off would be
regarding this as an ordinary funding
source
when they had
a small rehab to do
and 5 million at this point is a small
rehab
which is the only thing that's in the
bill so
it does need a lot of study
and it's going to need a lot of thought
i think over following years of what we
can do to help especially those two
counties
to fulfill
the obligation we've put on them
for uh paying for
most of the medicaid costs of their
of their residents when they
get too old to survive by themselves
thank you
thank you representative further comment
representative spielberg
thank you mr chairman
i appreciate the comments of both
representative abrami and representative
almi
as the sole representative
from sullivan county on the ways and
means committee i just want to go on
record
as saying
i understand
that creating a reserve fund
programmatically
to deal with all 10 counties in the
state over a span of decades
is probably just too heavy a lift
but i think that
the need of sullivan county is severe
for a county of 42 000 population
to
fund a 54 million
a capital
bond issue
which would then rest entirely on
real estate tax
which
already
is
at or near the highest in the state
so that for example claremont
and charlestown
share
the distinct position with say berlin
of
already having
an overwhelming real estate tax burden
so
i think that our delegation will be
looking for an opportunity
for one-time surgical earmarked funds
taking advantage of arpa and other funds
that may be available and i just beg
every member who's here
when that comes around
please
give us your support
for the discussion representative
tucker
yes
he did such a good job representatives
built free on
discussing sullivan
uh county coast county has two nursing
homes
we are heavily taxed and have tried to
keep up with capital expenditures
uh but we are in
we have trouble meeting on the operating
costs
at the same time that we keep up the
capital costs
so that i imagine that we will be very
much in the same position within the
next few years
of coming possibly for a one-time
appropriation
two nursing homes is a problem
and
geographically we're so large
that it's very difficult to go to one
that however is being mulled by some
people as a solution
so
i think
coast needs to do its own study and we
certainly need
legislators who are interested in this
topic to study also so thank you
further comments our discussion
saying none then i'm going to ask the
court to call
the vote on the motion of interim study
on house bill 1525
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting with representative abrami yes
representative turcotte yes
hillary
yes lasalle's
lange yes bernstein votes yes
mcguire
canadian
nunes
spillsbury
tudor
army
yes
ames yes
malui
representative thomas c schomburg yes mr
cork
representative tucker yes
go marlow
yes walner
yes
akan phillips
murphy yes
chairman major yes
the vote been 21-0
on the motion of itl
motion of interim study
it passes
and
without objection you go on consent
no objection you will go on consent
mr chair
yes just
i know this uh new uh system is a little
new for individuals
but we need to maintain a little bit of
um microphone um
discipline thank you i forgot the word
real quick uh because if too many mics
are on at any given time
not the other mics are not allowed to be
used
okay so they're just
a reminder to everyone
but i am
but i have the ability to shut everybody
down
he has an extra button
and i'll i'll try to uh are you saying
that you're a dick
okay the next bill
for exactly is house bill
dash fn
an act establishing a deferral from the
business profits tax and the business
enterprise tax for qualified limited
liability startups
represent a genetian
thank you mr
chairman i um
i believe that uh itl uh would be
appropriate for this bill and make a
motion for itl
okay
and i'd like to speak to you
makes the motion of itl do we have a
second second
second by representative turcotte
representation you want to speak to your
motion thank you mr chairman
well this is a well-meaning bill
and it's in its intent is to help
small businesses get started by
deferring their any uh tax burden they
may have on the bet business enterprise
tax
or the business profits tax
um
they're already in in the tax code i
believe allows this in that
until a business has reached at least 92
in
business receipts or 92 000
in i'm sorry 92 000 in net would they
pay
let me take that back until a business
has reached 92 000 in receipts they're
not going to pay the business profits
tax
and
the business enterprise tax already has
a threshold of two hundred and seven
thousand
if it's less than two hundred and seven
thousand gross receipts then a business
would have to have at least a hundred
and three thousand
um
dollar value on the enterprise value
of the business so
it those numbers are high enough that
small businesses have a chance to to get
started to see
if they can make a run at it without
paying any taxes so again i think
hb 1541 is well well intentioned
not necessary at this point
further discussion
no further discussion
then i'll ask the clerk to call the vote
of itl on hospital 1541.
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting with representative pat abrami
yes
representative turcotte yes
hillary yes the salads
yes
lang yes bursting votes yes
maguire
yes janigan yes
nunes yes
spillsbury
tudor yes
almi
yes ames
yes
malloy yes
the honorable thomas c schamberg mr cork
i vote yes thank you sir
representative tucker
go marlow yes walner
yes
hacken phillips yes
murphy yes chairman major yes
the vote been 21-0 for the motion of itl
on house bill 1541 it passes
objection
go on consent
i see no objection
house bill 1541 will go on consent
representative romney would you just
check and see if that amendment
is available on house bill 16 1063
everybody hang loose for a few minutes
i know
thank you representative tucker
i'm opening the executive session back
up
and we're going to deal with house bill
and act relative to the technical
changes to the administration of certain
taxes by the department of revenue
administration
we're going to start off
with a proposed amendment
representative romney
thank you mr chair i move amendment uh
2022-0300h
to house bill 610 1063 second
oh right you're right
i i reversed i
i uh retract my motion
i i move
ought to pass on house bill
1063.
that motion mr chairman
promotion has been made ought to pass on
house
bill 1063
by representative romney second by
representing
uh mr chairman point of order yes um
were we supposed to talk about the
amendment first
no
we're going to talk about it first okay
sorry thank you
right just as soon as
it's on the floor then we will
talk about the amendment
it's always confusing
okay representative romney
ought to pass
on house bill 1063 second by
representative schomburg now
representative rodney
okay this is the very last minute we
just received this uh
in the you're going to are going to make
the motion okay i move again uh
uh amendment
2022-0300h
to amend to house bill
okay
romney moves on to pass and second by
representati
representative romney so the essence of
house bill 1063 is it's a housekeeping
bill by the department of revenue
uh they they go through their statutes
and they find things that need to be
changed
and last minute i guess they
they caught a few other things they
wanted to change and it relates to rsa
21-j colon 28-a
and section 2 of the statutes
where it looks like
they're just changing some wording here
um and again we're all just seeing this
for the first time so
i i would suggest
mr chair we do have a representative of
uh
dra here who may be able to explain this
a little more than i can
but it looks pretty straightforward to
me
d.r.a
you want to
explain further
good morning my name is keen ming wong
from department revenue administration
tax policy council
so this
amendment to the bill is basically uh
the the crux of it is to
reduce on the postage charges
um that when we sent out the
notices to um for refunds that were
requested by the taxpayers um so
what this does is that when taxpayers
submit a um a request for refund if the
refund is granted in full what normally
happens
with the new system is that
a notice is sent out
even though if the
refund is granted info we will still
send out a notice saying okay yeah your
refund is now
approved in full
so
and so this amendment
wants to cut out that procedure in terms
of sending that notice when the refund
is granted in full and that notice will
only be sent out to the taxpayer
if the uh if it's a partial approval or
it was not approved at all
i'll take any questions if
any any questions
um
so
what it actually does is that if the
person is getting a full refund they
will just receive the full refund
that is correct thank you
it saves about six thousand mailings
a year
i don't i don't have to eat the number
in front of me but i'm assuming that's
right
all right i do have a question
any further questions yeah
so i recently received a letter from dra
saying that
i had made a mistake
and that
i was due a credit of nine dollars and
some odd cents
but the letter started out with the
phrase that it was in response
to my inquiry
actually i had not made an inquiry and
apparently that is and i i did call
there was a number and although i didn't
talk with the person who was on the
letter i talked with another
representative dra
and
that's on all the letters it says this
is in response to an inquiry it was not
in response to inquiry and this appears
that this would make a difference
that
i would not have known about this credit
if i had not received a letter even
though the beginning was
not correct
i now am aware that i need to give that
letter to my accountant
who will know that i have a credit of
nine dollars and some odd cents
for next year so
uh
are
you need to make sure that those letters
are correct that the person
knows that someone is looking this was
something found by dra on its own error
right i know it's
um
so i'm trying to see if
i can answer a question here
um probably um i think
the reason why those
uh there's a there's a standard verbiage
on the letters right now with the new
system
um and that might have been in there for
all the letters so we will definitely
have to go through that and uh
right because this only will work if the
person knows there's a possibility
that
right there's a refund coming
or credit being given
and if they haven't initiated it
themselves they wouldn't know about it
okay um yeah i hear you
um
however this amendment to the bill um is
not in that situation it's not for that
particular situation
um this amendment is for
taxpayers who are requesting refund
and
and the notices that goes out
for those requests
right
i received this morning from the dra
an email
for
further clarification let me just read
it to you
currently when a taxpayer requests a
refund or or credit on their tax return
we are required to send them written
notification
both
when we grant the requested refund or
credit when we deny the requested refund
or credit
we would like to send notifications only
if we are denying and whole or
importantly requested refund or credit
this change will prevent the mailing of
over 6 000 duplicate letters each year
we believe that the written notice is
unnecessary from a due process
perspective
when we have granted the taxpayers
request in full and therefore no appeal
opportunity results
and that's why only this specific
case
any further questions
yes
thank you mr chair it's not a question
but i would say that the taxpayer
receiving a check would be just as happy
that whether or not the letter came
thank you
any further comments or questions
saying none
then
we're ready to vote on the amendment
those in favor of the amendment raise
their hands
those opposed raise their hands
unanimous the amendment passes
now
representative bernstein
um
hb 1063 ought to pass as amended
representative romney i mean i mean
bernstein moves out to pass
with amendment
2022-0
second mr chairman second by
representative
any further
discussion or comment on the motion
about to pass with amendment
representative bernstein you can speak
to your motion
house bill 1063 makes three minor
technical changes to the statutes
administered by the department of
revenue administration we just heard
about the uh
chairman major with that and abrami with
the recent amendment you've heard of the
first change
second and uh you're going to want to
pay attention because this is thrilling
stuff
for business profits tax purposes
current statute directs taxpayers to
determine net operating loss using the
internal revenue code of 1996 this bill
updates the statutes to require the use
of the internal revenue code in effect
for the business profits tax which is
currently the internal revenue code
of 2018. this change will not result in
a meaningful difference in the amount of
nol permitted but will relieve taxpayers
of the onerous task of using a version
of the tax code that is 25 years old the
final change
due to
systems upgrade you can now
electronically file your research and
development tax credit application
house bill 1063 modernizes the language
of the relevant statute by replacing the
word postmarked with filed the term
filed is consistent with other dra
administered statutes
i encourage you
to vote yes on the otp
any further comments or questions
saying
phillips um i think there was a an
additional change to the meals and rooms
tax just updating it um from nine
percent to eight and a half percent
as well on page two
mr chairman
it's where the nine percent is removed
so that every time we change the tax
rate again they won't have to change
this right
okay thank you
okay
any further questions or comments
saying none i'm going to ask the court
to call the vote on ought to pass as
amended with
amendment 0300h
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting with representative patrick
obrami yes
representative chercott yes
hillary yes
let's alice yes
lang
yes bershteen votes yes maguire yes
genigion
nunes yes
spillsbury
tudor
almi
yes
representative ames yes
malui
yes
representative thomas c schamberg
yes mr kirk
thank you sir representative tucker yes
go marlo
yes walner yes
hacking phillips yes
murphy yes chairman major yes
it's a real nail biter mr chair 21 to
nothing
thank you representative bernstein
the motion about to pass with the
amendment passes
with a vote of 21 to zero on house bill
without objection it will go on consent
no objection
house bill 1063 will be on the consent
calendar
now
i have one other bill that
had an open question but the question
seems like it was answered this morning
and that's on the house bill 1430.
representative elmi
that was the question that you had asked
on
hospital 14 30. do you think it's
only you and i at this point have got
the response from carolyn lear because
i just copied it to you and she just
copied it back to you and me
so i could read off
that or
we're going to save it for a work
session
then we are through with executing
on
bills in the possession of
ways of means and we will continue
with a work session on the remaining
nine bills
and we will do them numerically
the idea is
to identify
on each of these remaining nine bills
uh the more information we need to make
a decision
do we need to
or do we have enough to make a decision
do we need to make an amendment
or anything else
so we'll go to a house bill
relative to taxation of income of new
hampshire residents and working remotely
for an out-of-state employer
mr chair
you want to talk a conversation
right
um
this this bill was put
submitted uh
because of the what massachusetts had
done during the peak of the
endemic
where they changed their rules
and they
in massachusetts where if you worked in
new hampshire
you work with a company that sometimes
you you go into the office in mass
sometimes you work at home
the portion of time you work at home you
were never taxed you prorate the the
amount
you only get tax
on mass tax when you're in in
massachusetts physically working they
changed their law
during the pandemic to say during their
state of emergency
that
that would no longer apply that that
people working in
at home
with offices in massachusetts would have
to pay the mass tax 100 percent
so this bill
appears to
say we
you know
we want to prevent that from happening
in the future
uh well actually the future the sponsor
thought it was still in place we found
out since
the hearing
that the massachusetts state of
emergency is has been lifted
and that this um executive order had
also been lifted
so there's there'd be no direct
impact of us passing this bill on
current employees that are working at
home because that's been lifted
uh the question becomes for the
committee
do we see any value here in passing this
anyway for future
situations that come up
and i think that's the point of
discussion that we get we need to have
so i'll leave it at that for a moment
any response representative
thank you mr chairman yes as a
co-sponsor of this bill
um we i do recognize that currently it
is not needed however
there's nothing stopping massachusetts
or any other state from
imposing something like this in the
future and i think it's it's still
necessary for us to pass this so we
protect new hampshire citizens
thank you
representative spellsbury
thank you mr chairman
like others i was upset by massachusetts
unilateral action
and i think the state does in fact have
an interest in protecting its
residents against attacks
on
work performed in new hampshire
the problem with the bill as it's
drafted is it's purely exhortatory it
just simply says
to massachusetts or any other state
don't do that
but there's nothing enforceable about it
and i think perhaps an amendment
that redirected it slightly would be
more
constructive so for example
i think
there are two elements that could be
helpful
in the event that a state does the same
thing in the future
one is a clear statement
of state interest
so as to underpin a claim of standing
before a court
and second
is perhaps an instruction
to the executive branch or the attorney
general that when such a situation
arises
they have an obligation to
engage in litigation
so
we understand that the
united states supreme court declined to
hear the case
this is not a situation where they
remanded it to a lower court it's it's a
rare example of original jurisdiction
which gives them the discretion to hear
cases between states
and i think that there was political
pressure on the court not to hear it
and i think they didn't want to take up
a case that they didn't feel
that they had to
resolve
i do think though i don't recall that it
was stated in the supreme court's
opinion
that a key underlying procedural hurdle
was standing
what is the standing of the state of new
hampshire to assert the claim for harm
to individual wage earners
so
my question is this
as written i don't think it's worth
passing
can we revise it
to focus on standing
and
on instruction to the attorney general
to actually wage the battle
represent
thank you mr chair um
the point that was just made seems to be
the the crux of the matter
as to give the state standing over
actions by other states we ran across
this earlier uh to a lesser well
actually to about the same degree with
the interstate sales tax
uh activity
this
falls into that same category
the state didn't have in place
a strong enough
position
and i believe this this bill
is
a vehicle for that to get done i think
it's up to this committee to come up
with a
strong position and i think we can get
some guidance from the attorney general
thank you
representative
thank you uh
this is about income taxation and
on there are a number of states that on
reach deep into the pockets and and
cities that reach deep into the pockets
of people who don't live in most places
but
but work there i think it's
probably well i don't think it's quite
the same as the sales tax one i would
really like to get a good discussion
with the attorney general about
on
what can be done and what's feasible
representative ames and followed by
representative romney
yeah i guess my uh
request for
work to be done in this study is uh did
not study this work session
is um
similar to representative omni's uh but
a little different i i'd like to uh i
find i find the language here
um
very broad and i want to be sure that
what's wrapped up into any language
that's the subject of a bill like this
is clear
so i would uh want to have from dra
information i'd like to have
a report or a discussion with dra on
the
taxes that we
we apply that we have the bet and the
bbt particularly
to
ensure that
we're not shooting ourselves in in the
foot so to speak and
and perhaps uh saying that some
aspect of our tax that may indeed reach
services that are physically performed
in another state
and take away our powered attacks and
implicitly
contradict the position we're taking
with our tax laws so i i just like to be
sure that we're not uh
on both sides of this
question
representative romney
thank you mr chair i did some i'm
concurring that we we need the guidance
of the attorney general's office on this
one
i think it would be helpful to
find out who the point person was in the
supreme court case
that
that wasn't really heard
but i'm sure that they're most familiar
with this so if we can determine who
that is that probably the person we want
to talk to
thank you thank you
we're fortunate this morning we do have
somebody from the attorney general's
office
roger
um
we would like that we'll set it up
before work session
any further
discussion on what we need to get more
information on
then we will
have a work session
on this
and hopefully
you could
provide that information so that i'm
scheduling this for a work session next
wednesday
thank
all you the next
bill
is house bill 1221-fn
relative to the rates of the business
profits tax and business enterprise tax
this bill reduces the rates of the
business profits and business enterprise
tax
for tax years ending on or after
december 31st 2023
members of the committee
do we need additional information on
this
mr chairman
representing yearly i spoke to the uh
sponsor of this bill of representing
daughter and uh she would be very happy
uh if we had a uh
work session on this bill to gain any
further information that we may need
okay and
does anybody have any suggestions on
what kind of information they need
projections uh something for uh from
information as to why it applies both uh
only to the bpt and not the bet or is
the offset continued into this bill
okay
all right mr chair i don't think that
should be a long
uh drawn out discussion i think that's
uh information that if we just sit down
or we have some open time we can go
ahead and
review that and come up with a
decision on our own
okay mr chair
representative oh i'm sorry
okay representative next chair
i think the information we need
is going to come too late
and that we need to really know
what's going to happen in april and
beyond
because that's when most of the filings
happen
and we have concerns about the ppp
refunds whether how many are there going
to be
a lot of refunds or not
and the credit carry forward issue is a
big one that we really won't know
so i mean about absolutely let's have
the let's have the uh
the work session on it but
those there's some pieces of the puzzle
that we we still don't know as to
how how are we really doing right now
uh because of the concern about
more about refunds this this april
filing
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman
the
90 to 100 million dollars that we may
have to be giving back in march april
on for ppp taxation that was done last
year
is
only the most firm of our worries we
don't know what market-based sourcing
switch
is
is going to do
to our returns
on
next year
we're going to be doing
starting single sales factor impact on
our revenues
that's extremely volatile and
it
seems likely that it would reduce the
bpt because we
export a lot more
on than we consume in this state and so
if we're switching to only in state
sales
we uh and ignoring property and ignoring
payroll
we may be losing
big time we don't know
then there's the credit carry forward
and then there's the economy which on
is going to be losing a fair amount of
federal
oomph that was keeping on pushing it
on and is going to have to be reacting
to inflation and is still reacting to
omicron
i
am
i think that a lot of us are severely
worried by
how much
surplus will have left in june
never mind next year and the finance
committee in its wisdom had
had
limited
the reduction in those tax cuts this
last time in order to be able to pass a
budget
that made sense to them
so
um
i really think that
it's going to be very difficult for us
to
have
enough foresight to figure out whether
we could afford to do this without
having to raise something else next term
thanks
[Music]
thank you mr chairman
um as i look at this i i agree we need
to be careful because we we don't know
uh how things may change and we also
have to um the credit carry over
certainly is a is an issue to be
cognizant of one of the things that i'm
i'm thinking and i'd like to
definitely hear from
dra in a work session
is possibly splitting this out because
when i look at the revenue
projection or revenue loss projection
it's it's the bet that has the much
bigger impact here
at about according to this chart 27
million
by 2025 27 million less
when i look at the bpt business profits
tax
it's about their projection is about 8
million less
by 2025.
and
so maybe we split this out where we we
keep the bet where it is at .55 but we
potentially lower the bpt
from 7.6 to 7.5
and the thought there is
not only is is the change much less
but
when when companies
think about i mean part of the strategy
here is lowering the bpt
and bet
to have business encourage businesses
from from other states or just people
start businesses
they're gonna most of the time they they
look at it and they say gee what's the
business profits tax because not a lot
of other states have something called a
business enterprise tax
that top line number is compared quite
often so
i think it's an advantage for new
hampshire
to to say we have a 7.5
business profits tax and let's leave the
bet as it is
in the current law at 0.55 so my
proposal would be we look at just
lowering the bpt but i agree i'd like to
hear from dra and get some more
information as well
further questions or comments
mr chairman if we were going to consider
that i think that we would need the be
uh the dra to recalculate
how much each of how much that loss
would be
and
i i for one do not believe that this
minor
tax
reduction on the bpt or in fact any of
the ones that we've been doing has an
effect on
bringing in businesses to this state so
in general i'm
opposed but
thank you
this whole business of
tax reduction
is something that
is not clear
you don't really know what's
going to happen
you know
right now we're sitting in the rainy day
fund a couple hundred million dollars
but in that rainy day fund of a couple
hundred million dollars
is the credit carry forward
credit carried forward it's like 275
million
that's not our money
it could disappear
we may have to give it away right away
in addition
there's a about a hundred million
dollars in the ppp that we're going to
have to get back because we we were
taxing it before we said we're not going
to tax it
there's another thing
is that
our revenues are looking great
and why are they looking great
they're looking great because all the
stimulus that has been put into this
over the last two years
they've kept all of our businesses alive
and when you keep them alive and you
don't have the expenses because the
government's paying for them you're
going to make a profit
that profit is going to go away part of
it's going to go away after the stimulus
is a stop
because you can't
provide this to us all the time until
somebody pays for that stimulus
so
we have to
figure out
all the tax cuts that we've done so far
need to settle down
and see what happens
before we start
adding more tax cuts to it
and i think that's why we need to go
look at this more deeply
in a work session
so
representative
thank you mr chair and i think and i
apologize i haven't been around a lot
much in this community but i'm i'm
available now but uh the revenue
projections that we look at and and
ongoing revenue projections i think play
a big part in this as you said you know
we know we have ind tax cuts coming
along the line down the road and a lot
of other things so i think looking at
this thing is a big picture not through
a straw
is extremely important so as we're
moving forward i'd like us to seize look
at those uh have the lba do you know
give us our budget projections out for
five or ten years and look at you know
the what-if scenarios what if we drop
this what if we do that so we can see
what that looks like
i think that's extremely important to
understand tax policy as a whole for the
state
thank you
you remind me
that's why
starting friday
we have a full day of
economic briefings
and on this friday
we have a full day of economic briefing
starting this friday and this friday
we'll hear from the lba
and they'll go over
all the time all the taxes that they
have
how they've been where we are and
hopefully give us some projections
do the same thing with the
dra and then we'll hear from housing
we'll hear from
labor
and others
you may get tired of it
and then the following friday will do
the same thing but we'll do it with
economist so we'll find out
how the economy has been
how it is now and what's projected in
the future
nationally regionally
and how it will affect new hampshire
and we will redo some of these things
later on after
march and april the
revenue months coming in
so we'll have a better handle on see
we can separate the ppp and the stimulus
and look at the regular revenues coming
in we don't have that information right
now
but we're going to work at it
any further comments on house bill 1221
we're going to go to a work session on
12 21.
the next is house bill 1430
14 30.
an act
repealing the tax on rentals of motor
vehicles under the meals and rooms tax
and representative had asked from some
information the dra we received that
information this morning
and we'll be able to go through that in
a work session
uh
the next is house bill 14.
i think at that meeting the
american car rental association also
wants to speak
yes
and
anybody that would like to speak make
themselves available because this has
been
put into this week's calendar
that we're having a work session on
these specific nine bills next wednesday
the next is house bill 1450
an act including agricultural resources
under the land and community heritage
investment program
what kind of new information do we need
on this belt
comments
mr jackson
repton lying followed by representative
tucker
mr chair as i remember the public
hearing on this and we heard from i uh
i believe it was the uh
chairman of the commission of
agriculture that
this is already covered and that there
was really no need to change the law
that under natural resources they they
consider agriculture and farming so i'm
not sure what new information we would
need to get it was pretty clear even
from
uh the people from l-chip that this was
also um
that they they do already put into
conservation large agricultural tracks
so i'm not sure that there is any more
information we really need to get for
this and maybe an ital motion would be
appropriate okay
representative
tucker well if if we are going to look
into the idea of agricultural resources
being protected i think it would be
important to know how many land trusts
in new hampshire
have
directed themselves towards preserving
agricultural resources
my impression is that it's a lot
but
it would be good idea to find out how
many
land trusts there are that are
trying to preserve
our agricultural resources in the state
in other words there there are other
organizations other than l-chip
that are directing themselves to this
are you working on that
i can try to find out just send out
but
i think it's quite typical but i so
perhaps this is something like the
society for the new hampshire
protection of new hampshire forests
will actually know how many land trusts
are available to working on this
looks like this is the only issue that's
holding this bill up at this point well
if
if that's the only issue let's uh
we can find out some other time but if
it's ready to move
uh that's that's fine too okay then we
should be able to deal with this at our
work session right yeah
that this bill had two parts and the
other one is taking more money from
general and education trust funds to
l-chip
so
um i'm not in favor of that myself
because we don't know what our finances
are
and i think that
finance itself ought to be
dealing with that but
do you know of anything that could
we would need additional information in
order to be able to act on this bill no
okay
representative
yes i agree with representative valami
it does take money it does
require an additional quarter percent be
taken out of the uh
real estate transfer tax
and that that amounts to about five
hundred and six thousand dollars
annually based that was based on last
year's
what we knew the transactions were
it was pretty high here in terms of
housing transactions and
in terms of the revenue was pretty high
so
you know and 33 percent of that
506 000 would go to education and 67
would go to general fund
so i'm ready to go on this but i'm
willing to
wait and
and you know have a work session on it
but
so but i don't know what we're going to
resolve there i think it's either either
we want this or we don't but thank you
we don't have any new information then
we'll be exacting this
next wednesday
house bill 1478
relative to relative to the business
profits tax applicable to certain large
low-wage employers
representative
thank you mr chair you know again at
least if i recall a public hearing on
this bill it was
there was bipartisa consensus bipartisan
consensus that
this bill was unconstitutional based on
the equitable
and proportional clause of our
constitution and i'm not sure what new
information we need beyond that to just
itl this bill
anybody else
a question mr chairman representative
lange
uh
who is the authority that this is a
unconstitutional uh
uh
uh direction that we would be taking
sure absolutely susan almighty agreed
with me
mr chairman
representative i i don't believe i was
quite that definitive about it
i think on and
on my explorations on this have been
that
we really wouldn't know until we took it
to the court
whether
it was likely to be considered
unconstitutional or not
on
but
also there are
major
changes that would need to be made to
make this bill work as at this point
it looks like if you are a multinational
with
a company in honduras which is paying
less than 15 an hour that you would have
to pay the higher tax in new hampshire
even if it was constitutional
or
or you're paying 15
14 and 10 cents to somebody in texas who
is cleaning bathrooms
that you would be
have to pay the extra tax in new
hampshire
on i think it would need a fair amount
of work if
we wanted to go forward with this
my view is that this is something that
belongs in the labor committee
dealing with minimum wages
but
there is dispute in my side of the clock
of the committee
unless somebody can come up with
something you really know
this should be ready for exactly
representative romney yes i i want to i
want to concur with representative this
is
really a labor bill
that's disguised as a waste of means
bill that's a way to phrase it and i
think uh i'll just talk i'll speak for
our caucus uh
we don't think this this bill is is
ready for prime time thank you mr
chairman
thank you mr chair um
representative almi was kind when she
was a chair to
get professor hearn to put together a
little brief on uh equitable and
proportional
that would be your
expert on that and uh
in reading his
or re-reading his little um
brief yeah this
doesn't do it in addition the sponsor of
the bill
named businesses to be discriminated
against
and you can't do that in the bill
you can't do that in any law
representative
thank you mr chairman uh as a member of
the current labor committee and on my
third term there
this is obviously a backdoor attempt at
a minimum wage bill and i would
be very in favor of an itl motion on
this bill
thank you for your comment
i agree with representative turcotte
so we'll have some work to do next
wednesday
get some more bills out the door
the next is house bill 1494.
relative property tax exemption
concerning certain communication
services releases
representative
yes i i thought it'd be valuable to hold
this bill uh for a work session um
i reached out
to
uh
james jerry from who is the director
of municipal and property division of
the department of revenue and he's
willing to come in and talk to us about
the ramifications of this bill so we
have somebody who'll come in and talk to
this bill so thank you
thank you mr chair
if i uh this was was this the bill that
was talking about broadband i'm trying
to remember if this was the one
so my concern with this bill was giving
a broad-based widespread tax break with
the idea that it would be used to help
the last mile conversation
by giving them the tax break they would
reinvest back into the broadband to do
the last mile conversation the problems
were no actual provisions in the bill to
make them reinvest for the last mile
we'd just be giving a tax break without
a benefit of actually expanding
broadband within our communities
um
and and then you would look at
communities like manchester which
necessarily don't have
uh very many places where you can't get
broadband and you look at communities up
in coast county which has a lot but we
still be giving a tax break to
manchester while coast county has no
ability to expand broadband
i did bring up a general idea of
making this enabling statute to allow a
municipality to be able to enable a tax
break locally and use and do a kind of a
pilot program where uh
the
broadband
providers could say hey look if you give
us this tax break we'll agree to
to invest that much money back into your
community to expand and then it would be
a local enabling enabling uh provision
right so if my community has problems
with with broadband the last mile
conversation we could choose to extend a
tax break to our carrier and say hey
look we're going to give you a tax break
totaling 150 thousand dollars we want
you to do 150 000 miles 150 000 worth of
infrastructure upgrade and we'll trade
you that tax break for the upgrade to
help our community
um and i i don't know whether anybody's
interested in doing i'm happy to take
the on to doing a book to see do an
amendment to allow that enabling statute
to allow local communities to be able to
waive this tax locally and but only in
favor of doing basically a trade with
the with the provider otherwise i think
it's just a tax break
you make a good point
would you
put together an amendment
absolutely
anything else
on house bill 1494
mr chair
oh yeah
over in the corner
mackin phillips thank you mr chair i
think it might be worthy to have dra
produce some sort of analysis about what
kind of fiscal impact this might make uh
it'd be worthy to just review that
information i think if we're in
consideration
of the bill
i don't know i don't know i
that was something that i think was
brought up during the original testimony
and
it might be worth checking out
thank you
anybody who's interested in helping or
comment a conversation about that
amendment feel free to reach out to me
romney yes uh representative phillips
yeah i i think we should do that now
when i call
to set that up i'll i'll see if they can
quickly put some together we were handed
something out by uh
by uh an assessor
san soucy's company
but it was just for
his his towns not not all the towns and
cities so
um yeah i think it'd be interesting to
see what the what the impact would be on
all all towns the 200 plus that we have
in cities thank you
okay
the next
yes i'd just like to express interest in
representative lang's
amendment uh being one of the san souci
towns there which i hadn't realized he
was doing ours
now on
it
the towns at this point have very little
leverage against the cable companies to
get them to do
on
to do upgrades for the parts of their
towns that don't have
access at this point which
there is a mile long stretch between
lebanon and hanover which
they kept in the dark
and which we haven't been able to do
anything about
but
on
this would give
give individual towns that were really
concerned with this
some leverage if they want to use it
i think it's a good idea
so the two of you guys can work together
thank you mr chair i'll take care of it
all right the next
is
house
relative to the termination of the frm
victim contribution recovery fund
would like to hear from the attorney
general
as to the status of that how it operates
what is how it's
broken down
um whether this does or does not uh make
whole
uh or and
what actions the executive branches has
taken to correct the deficiencies that
were pointed out both by the sec the
banking commissioner and within their
own office regarding the handling of the
the issue
we have somebody from the attorney
general's
hi i'm tom donovan i'm the director of
charitable trust at the attorney
general's office uh we don't usually
show up at uh ways and means so um thank
you for uh hosting us
this morning um
the reason i'm speaking is because um
rsa chapter
359p assigns to the director of
charitable trust the responsibility to
hire
a
administrator for the frm victims
compensation fund
um
the uh that fund began the legislation
was first enacted in 2016
and then in
2021 there was an appropriation made of
10 million dollars for that fund
and so it was with that appropriation
that we were able to then go out and
hire someone that person began work
in november
and
um
last week we uh sent out the
applications for compensation under that
there was a news release as to that and
that's up and
uh running right now so that's the
process we're following what the
legislature has told us to do in rsa 359
p this bill
um
hb 1509 would terminate that fund that's
a policy matter for um
for the legislature to consider i'd note
there's another
bill
uh i think it's in the judiciary
committee hb 12
35 which would fold the
frm victims compensation fund into the
victims
crime victims compensation system
that's in a different committee
happy to answer any questions
representing
yes thank you mr chair um there was
quite a lot of controversy at the time
this bill was hurt
there was a
dramatic situation in the
governor's council with
a resignation of the of a commissioner
there was
some complaints by the sec
and there was some pointed out at least
in the press some
quote unquote deficiencies in the um
in your own office
could you
give us some information about what is
being done to correct those so
representative ulery all of that
happened before
my time at the attorney general's office
wasn't saying it was you and uh
i'm just saying um i'm here to speak to
um
the uh
fulfilling what the legislator the
legislature
set forth in in the statute that's so
is there some
way you can get somebody from the office
to come in next wednesday to answer
questions proposed by representative
yearly
so
you're asking about questions about
things that happened a decade ago
i don't know
that i but i will go back and ask
but you're asking uh things that go back
in time
representative
thank you on
i think
that this bill does not
really require going back and figuring
out trying to figure out yet again
who was wrong about what which i
remember wasn't really completely
resolved at the time
but
i think that
the legislature had a fair amount of
of
voice in the mess that was created at
that time
um but
what
i would like to learn is your
how your process is going to work since
it looks
like
you have to wait until you think you
have all of the applicants
for the fund before you can distribute
any money
correct there's a deadline that was set
forth in the statute
um
and
i don't want to mistake i'm not mindful
of it but it's in
may i believe
and um and we've reached out to the
mailing list that we have
of uh
potential claimants
and
there are other
people in the victims community that
have contacts as well so the
administrator will be
continuing with reach out
in that regard
there's plenty of time
there's plenty of time to distribute all
of the money before
this bill would repeal it
well
the
interestingly
the um
the current
statute says that
on december 31
so nothing is going to be distributed
until december 31
of this year
yes it's it the way it's written it's
like it can be made on december 31 of
each year
um
i i think that
is partially
reflective of the original funding
stream now there's 10 million dollars
that's been appropriated
if you recall prior to 2021
this fund was to be
sourced from donations
so i think there may have been some
thought that money would trickle in over
years
i envisioned that
that this work can be completed
and so the distributions could be made
on december 31 of of this year but the
statute does contemplate it could go on
and it would be then december 20 31 of
the following year as well
mr chairman follow-up fellow
on so
will by december 31 will you have both
tranches the 10 million dollars
yes representative almighty was
referring to the fact that
the
amendment appropriated
5 million
as of last june july 1 or june 30 and
then the second
tranche if you will will come in in june
30th of 2022 so there will be a full 10
million dollars
as of
that would be available at that point
so you would be sorry follow up you
would be capable of distributing all the
money
before
the deadline for this bill to repeal
uh yes uh but i put an asterisk on that
because
there's
um there are formulas in there it
depends on how much it's claimed
and then um the amount of compensation
that is available is 50 up to 50
um so i i don't know how
it would be speculating for me to
predict whether the full 10 million
dollars would be
subject to distribution
thank you i could could i just
one last follow-up could i ask
can you find out from
someone in the attorney general's office
whether
on there is any state that has ever
reimbursed investors without losing a
lawsuit
in similar kinds of cases
um
i am i'm
i could ask i'm not sure
i would
take the answer to the bank though
okay
right
i have a number
representative
romney followed by representative tucker
representing early representatives
okay representative
thank you
my concern is that this is a classic
bait and switch i know i think this is a
really bad look if we if we pass this
bill
uh
but i i have a question for
representative walner you're the
minority leader
in the in um
over in finance
uh obviously it would this this was my
understanding that this was in house
bill 2.
um my question is was that how
hard was this debated in how and finance
can you recall because none of us really
knew about this until we voted the
budget
so it was it's in there uh was it did it
come in as another bill that became part
of arsenal too can you recall
i think it did come in as a bill and
then uh division one
held the bill and it was rolled into
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
it came in as a separate bill i can't
remember the number of it or much about
it but
then division one held that bill
and then it rolled into house bill two
okay
thank you
thank you that's my memory someone else
may have a different memory
represented early
thank you mr chair um
the
recurring question
and i think we can get some of that
information that uh representative olney
asked from
ask ols research uh as regarding other
states but this fund in no way makes
whole
any individual investor does it
so this uh representative uhlery the
statute
uh
creates a formula
um and
there is
debits and credits to it and at the end
there's a claim amount
and then the maximum that can be
distributed is 50 of that claim amount
could you provide the committee with uh
a charter graph of the the that
flowchart of how that formula is creed
operates
it's
it's right in the statute um the
legislature created the form actually
it's it's quite unusual so
um i'm not trying to dodge your question
representative eulery but it's right in
three rsa359p
follow up
uh thank you for for that uh
information
um
is there any way that you could get uh
someone from your office uh to to
help advise this uh
committee
since we deal with the finances along
with
representative waldner's committee
as to what is being done to
prevent
a recurrence of this
thank you mr chair
representative ames
thank you
my question goes to
uh what part of the
information that you're going to be
dealing with
and producing will be public
uh we're dealing with individual names
and uh amounts
uh there'll be an amount applied for and
there'll be amount distributed
assuming this goes through and not
somehow short-circuited by this bill
so
what will the public know
and
yeah
uh representative ames that's a good
question we haven't uh come to a
conclusion on that the
statute
requires that um
claimants provide
um tax return information
um
which is typically not public and may be
exempt from the right to know law
uh but i would imagine that the
distribution amounts
certainly would be subject to
right to know the names and
any distribution amounts would be
thank you
represent spellsbury
thank you mr chairman
i was listening with interest to the
exchange between representative olney
and the ag's rep regarding dates
speaking to you mike
sure
so
you know on an initial reading of this
bill i understand it to be uh an effort
to reverse the provisions that were
incorporated into hb2
and i personally am not interested in
revisiting that and would not would not
vote for that
but
the second provision is essentially just
a sunset
so i'm curious
even if section one was dropped
and therefore we would not be
reversing the decisions the legislature
made in hb2
is there a value in having a sunset
provision
in light of what you were saying about
these ongoing annual
and potential donations and december
31st payments
um
so first of all we're not taking a
position on this bill this is a policy
matter so the attorney general's office
is not taking position on uh
hb
1509. um there is a provision in the
current legislation for
um sunsetting of of whatever is left
over
in the current
legislation so that if there is money
left over at some point
um and it's a few years away
um and i
i don't want to quote but it's several
years away
before it would be
the money would lapse whatever's left
over in that fund
okay so there is a provision that would
sunset it but it's out in the future
correct
representative
thank you mr chairman uh just to clarify
somebody had asked a question
about the original
where this frm
how it got into hb2 it did come across
in the original hb2
as part of the omnibus bill of hb2 it
was not a separate bill incorporated
later it was originally in it
can ask clarifying one question
representative was that was that in the
was that did that come across in the
governor's budget
that's correct okay thank you
mr chair uh question for you
can we ask jennifer to get that
provision or maybe the whole section of
hb2 that pertains to this that may be
helpful
to
uh some of the questions that have been
asked
yeah about the sun setting and all of
that jen could you copy
that section of house bill 2
relative to the frm
and make it a bill
the senate e-mail
representative mr chairman and
there was an original
frm fund law which
i think
hb2 was modifying so maybe we need that
piece of it too
to understand what we're looking at
i think we need to look at hb2
in order to be able to
identify it and
get it
and then we would go and look for the
rest of the law
okay
it's like tracking
the statures
one refers to another one that it refers
to somebody else
okay
i don't see any other hands up
thank you
should be an interesting work session on
that next week
the next
is house bill 1524 establishing a
national service alumni
attraction and retention fund
mr chair
representative schamberg
i got the honor of looking at this
well i volunteered for it
but uh
just a quick summary
this bill only creates a fund for
depositing of american rescue plan
monies grants or donations it does not
determine how much of the recovery
how much of the resources of the 584
million dollars that's still out that's
coming to the state will be used
it creates a fund that can allow grants
to be matched dollar to dollar for
employers
and for colleges and no it will be at no
additional cost to taxpayers new
hampshire taxpayers but if there are
questions about the setup of just the
fund itself by this committee
i think we should invite gretchen
stallings the executive director of
volunteer new hampshire
and steve epstein volunteer new
hampshire board chair
to attend and give their expertise on
why
this creation of this fund is so
important for workforce development
this is a first bill that's going to go
a
second bill will go to i think the
finance committee or
i do not know mr chair where it's going
next why i came here i do not know other
than we're just asked to create
a workforce fund
an alumni workforce fund right
it's not going to another committee
it is not going to another committee so
it's just going to be this committee to
either create or not create
thank you i think it's coming to this
committee because we're in charge of
dedicated funds
uh
but on
one of the key aspects of this for me is
to try to get treasury or someone to
tell us how much money is sitting there
in arpa
for new hampshire that is
on could be used for this apparently
there's a section in arpa that is for um
for exactly this kind of thing
and i think the money hasn't been maybe
there are seven
seven categories or eight categories
under arpa
and workforce development is one of them
and 19 million dollars went to that
portion
but
only
410 million has been spent on the 497
billion that came in on the first round
and there's
the rest of the money is coming in may
of this year
so uh
how they divide it up i do not know so
madam chair i mean
ranking member on me
that is the answer on that one i
treasury might be a good answer
yeah i think treasury could help us
because we're never sure when we're
looking at these things also what the
date on them is
representative schoenberg would you send
me the names
of these people
yes sir i'll send them to you
further questions
yeah but this has been a question of
mine you know i was involved with one of
three people in rockingham county to
come up with our plan to spend 60-ish
million dollars
we came up with our plan completely
submitted it to the treasury and we've
already got half the payment i guess
there were a lot of towns and so forth
our counties have gotten their money
uh i to me it's a puzzle as to what the
plan is of the state the complete plan
that would be of interest
um
and i'll take your word for it
representative schaumburg i always do
that this is maybe representative romney
as well that this does fall under the
guidelines of the treasury u.s treasury
in terms of
legitimate way of spending that money so
but i i really have no idea what the
state plan is
and whether there's
money to additional money that's out
there that we we can work with so thank
you
that's just a statement more than
anything else mr chair
i i would like to know that too because
everybody's saying it's going to come
from opry
so chairman i don't know if we could get
gopher to talk with us
it's the it's i was thinking of the new
hampshire treasury not the fed treasury
trying to talk to the fed treasury is
kind of hard
but
but gopher
is apparently the one that
is handling all of this still and and
maybe they could explain some of this to
our committee because it's also relevant
to our revenue estimates
that's a good point
further questions comments
we have our work to do on house bill 15
24.
the last one house bill 1565
relative to the opioid abatement trust
fund
what new information do we need
mr chair
representative the prime sponsor
gave us all this morning an amendment
she'd like to speak to
i'm sorry
yeah the the prime sponsor um aaron
representative aaron
uh
gave us an amendment this morning and
plus say some of the chart here
that you'd like to speak to uh at our
uh next work session on this bill i
think we give it a courtesy for that mr
chair
he's the prime sponsor here
where is it
good morning thank you
committee members and
chairman major
so this morning i presented a
an amendment to this bill to address
some of the
questions that were directed to me
during the hearing
and
that's the amendment
yes sir
so basically what i uh what i did was to
clear up some of the
language having to do with
the
uh allocation factor and how the
the calculation is clearer in this
amendment
um
because
the original bill had some language in
it that seemed kind of a little
wasn't clear as to what the calculation
really was
so i i fixed that in there
and i also added
some of the items that were in the
senate bill
there's a companion
there's a senate bill that also
uh changes some language in the same
stat in in the same statute having to do
with the
opioid abatement trust fund
so what i did was i added in what the
distribution of the funds should be
based on the most recent decennial
census instead of
the 2020 census
so we don't have to go back and change
that ever
of each qualifying county and political
subdivision that joined the national
litigation prior to september 1st 2019
according to following formula so the
formula is the distribution shall be
calculated by multiplying the settlement
amount
by the population factor and the
allocation factor where the population
factor is derived by dividing
each qualifying counties and
municipalities population by the state's
total population
and the allocation factor is set at 40
percent so i also gave you
a spreadsheet
that shows you
what the change
in the fund would be let's say
you're reading are you referring to the
amendment
yes and what part of the amendment
that is um
in the first part
uh for section two
secretary it would be helpful if she
gave us the lines dropping the line
number line four
yes thank you paige
one point one eleven to fourteen thank
you yeah
sorry about that
so if you look at the spreadsheet that i
also
distributed you can see
the um
what the
population factors would be
in uh e
as
in column e
column f
is the factor that's used now
and as you can see
in column
h and column i
shows the difference between what
the current distribution was and what
the settlement distribution would have
been
with
this
new allocation factor in place
okay
so with the with the current the way the
current allocation formula works is in
column h say for example
um
belmont
received
hundred and 2315
dollars and sixty eight cents but with
the new allocation factor that this bill
proposes they would have received six
thousand one hundred seventy five
dollars and fourteen cents and that
would go for their
opioid treatment programs
so this the new allocation factor also
take it it removes this population
penalty that we talked about during the
hearing
so column h is current
column h is the current
uh
this is one distribute this is one
settlement the mckinsey settlement
and the um
the settlement distribution in column h
is what was distributed from that
settlement
had this
bill hp 1565 been
in effect
the column i would be what those
entities would have received
instead
and as you can see it's significantly
more money
but yet we're still leaving a million
two hundred and ninety two thousand
eight hundred twenty nine dollars in the
fund which is a significant amount of
money
so if any other municipalities wanted to
apply for grants for from this fund
through the opioid commission
then you know there's certainly a a nice
pool of money for these other
municipalities to draw from
in the meantime what's happened is
so the total settlement was
two million seven hundred sixty two
thousand three hundred ninety four
dollars from the mckinsey settlement
and
um
only
uh
what is it 414
what is it i guess the
[Music]
2 348 035
dollars was um distributed out
i'm sorry that's what's left over yes
so
you can see that there the opioid
commission's sitting on a lot of money
that could have been
distributed out to the entities that
could have used it right away and
instead it's just sitting there
but anyway i'm so that that's
part one part of the um
amendment
um
the other part of the amendment
adds in um
the
part where that says the county nursing
home supervisor a designee that's his
page two line five
county nursing home supervisor or
designee appointed by the new hampshire
association of counties instead of the
governor
and um we're adding in another um
in lines 13 to 16
that we're supporting evidence-based
prevention programs and services
including efforts to promote healthy
drug-free lifestyles reduce isolation
build skills and confidence
and facilitate community-based
prevention efforts
so
basically
this amendment is just cleaning up
some of the
calculation language
that's really the the major thrust of
this
questions
representation
thank you mr chairman
uh
first
our chair likes to have
engineering diagrams
that that
show where the money is going and i
think that this would be a big help for
a lot of us
just boxes saying okay the money this is
the money that came in from the
settlement
on
this portion went to the advisory
council
this went to
each
town by this formula and would go by
that other formula
on
this money goes to each county
and i think that would make it a lot
easier to try and follow this
but
also
the way i
look at it
the towns
the one town in 12 cities that signed on
to this agreement which mine didn't
because they have the same theory i do
of this
um it turns out i found out
they on
are
um
they are triple dipping
they get the money from the count their
money from the county they get their own
money and then they can can go after
grants
and
every other
town
in the state
who also is having major opioid problems
is
getting
one dip
instead of three
and um believe me my town has major
opioid problems
but
our city manager
signed that handshake with whoever was
on it i don't know but he was
and he
uh felt that
the neighboring towns around us also
have major problems which is true
and the talent on the major
just about every town in this state has
to be touched by it
it would
it would be nice if we could get
somebody from the opioid abatement
management whatever that group is called
the advisory committee
to talk to us about what they're doing
and why they haven't done much yet if
they haven't done much yet
and what they're planning on doing
because
we're kind of
dealing out a statewide
approach to this and it'd be nice to
know what we're
exchanging it for
mr chair
if i may
may i request that uh our
county manager from sullivan county come
and talk about the issue of double or
triple dipping
so that he can clarify that that may not
be that the case
we can okay we'll do it right now okay
thank you
all right thanks mr chair uh derek
ferland the sullivan county manager i
guess in response to the the perception
that there could be triple dipping
um i can speak for sullivan county and
say that with the programs that we run
at the county
they are completely
distinct from whatever programs the city
of claremont
which is in sullivan county
would use these funds for so the city of
claremont
will not be accessing the funding that
sullivan county would receive so there's
no double dip from that perspective
as far as whether or not the city of
claremont may or may not or even
sullivan county for that matter
take its distribution and still apply
for grant funding well that's a matter
for each entity to decide based on the
programming that they have
obviously that process is separate and
the commission
is establishing the rules about how
entities might apply for those funds and
whether or not they would factor in
um
whether they whether that entity already
received a distribution or is one of the
entities that was not part of the of the
litigation
that's really up to them uh i guess it
would all be needs based or at least i
would suspect it would be impart needs
based
as we mentioned during the testimony the
decision to join or not was a very very
low threshold
each entity had to make its own mind up
as far as whether they wanted to join
and they had about a 15 month window to
do so so
i don't know that any
of the 23 entities should be necessarily
penalized
because of the other subdivisions that
decided not to join but the issue of
double dipping i think is is um
is really a non-issue because each
county has its own programs that they
need to support and fund whether or not
they would partner with either
non-profits within the county or even
the municipalities is is i think a
matter that's best left to them
[Music]
any further
thank you
on is it not true that
the way you're doing this the city of
claremont's population gets included in
the county population
in
doing
what we've got is a hundred percent of
the
state
population
getting
money out of out of this distribution
and then
on
municipalities
getting separate money out of this
distribution and all of it has to add up
to another hundred percent
so um
and as i understand it it's requiring
that
the city of claremont or the city of
belmont or whichever
be in their population be included again
in
the waiting for the county
it's included in the county's waiting
and it's included in its own city
waiting
yes representative that's essentially
the population penalty that was as as
discussed earlier
the original legislation essentially
deducted municipal populations from the
county shares
and because we each have our separate
and distinct
opioid abatement programs and activities
that was one of the things that we
sought to remedy with this proposed
legislation because
sullivan county's programs
um do include a lot of people from the
city of claremont it's it's relatively
proportional with our inmate population
therefore
the
the drug abuse programming
that we offer
needs to account for that population if
it was deducted
but the city of claremont's population
is counted at 100 percent well they get
the full amount for their programming
and the county share is we thought
unfairly reduced by that population
again that's why we had to change the
math and the formula which i think was
simplified with the amendment
um but but the premise was
this population penalty is is punitive
in that it only affects the counties but
the counties have their own programs
that are separate from the
municipalities
thank you but this is a population
penalty isn't it
on
only
if you accept we accept
the
your conclusion that
you are the forefront of the opioid
problem in new hampshire
instead of the opioid problem being
universal across new hampshire
and affecting places like littleton and
i presume say i don't know did salem
sign up for this they're not only cities
seem to have been approached
i think salem is outside of this too
i can't speak to who was approached like
i said there was a 15-month plus window
i think it was the information was was
publicly available
um
i don't know i'm not i'm not going to
make a value judgment about whose
programs are more important i can i can
simply say that from a dollar
perspective
uh the programs that we run in our
county jail
very confident that they would dwarf
whatever the municipal programs would be
whether it's medical medically assisted
treatment
the clinicians and the case managers
that we have that actually provide
the in-house
treatment services on a daily basis
those are expensive
and um
i think they're all important i think
the front lines are in multiple
um
locations whether it's in the city a
town or even a county
but there's no denying that the county
programs are significant and they are
costly
and i just think that the
fixing this population penalty as we
dubbed it
is a critical component and i think it's
a fair and reasonable way of of
distributing these funds to have the
biggest impact most directly
and uh in an efficient manner
any further
questions if not thank you
thank you very much appreciate it if you
have any other questions please
feel free to contact me via email
appreciate it
uh mr buffett do you have anything to
say
can you clarify the
triple
so
sure
thank you mr chairman
uh i'm happy to do that and i should
also say that i'm a member of the
commission the opioid abatement
commission to the extent that there are
questions about
the process and where we are i'm happy
to uh answer those um for the record my
name is james befetti i am an associate
attorney general
so um
the
the population penalty that that they
just referred to
i would actually call it a double
counting of people
so if you look at the original bill
you don't want to count people twice
because that gives an unfair advantage
to those counties that had more
political subdivisions who
uh who joined
because otherwise you can't get to a
hundred percent so for example
hillsborough county
both the city of nashua and the city of
manchester
um hired contingency free counsel
and filed lawsuits
so if you did this distribution formula
and you did not deduct the population
of manchester and nashua then you would
count those people twice because you
would count the population of
hillsborough county total
and then you would and then you would
give them um per person uh some
distribution formula 15 is what the is
what the current law says
and in addition you would count them
again to give an additional 15 by
population to nashua and to
manchester
so those counties that had bigger
communities who
filed
lawsuits
those those those populations of those
communities were deducted from the
counties to be fair to everyone else in
the state it's not
it's not a population penalty it's it's
a protection against double counting
people so
some counties like rockingham
rockingham only had a couple of
communities that that hired contingency
free council to file these lawsuits
so
if you look at in that first
distribution for that mckinsey
settlement the county that got the most
money
was rockingham because
they had only a few communities in the i
think it was just derry in londonderry
in the entire
county of rockingham that filed all the
other political subdivisions in
rockingham county including exeter and
plaistow uh
and uh and any of the other communities
who didn't file
because they didn't they wouldn't have
qualified for that 15
so the county ended up actually
benefiting because there were fewer
communities that had uh had had hired
this council and filed these lawsuits
and i'm happy to speak to the to this
issue about the work of the commission
if that's
helpful i know representative army had
questions
representative romney
i don't know if there's a question for
you or for the
prime sponsor who handed out this chart
have you seen this chart i have not
okay um maybe helpful if if he did
i i just want to make sure
the grand total population is one point
three one six
two nine two fifty six
uh i i wanna know
again maybe it's not a question for you
i can ask if you don't mind mr chair
just to clarify this
so let's take the hillsborough example
and
manchester
so when we have the hillsborough
population 2010 census
in this chart
is that really the hillsborough census
or is it the hillsborough census minus
manchester and or in any other
uh town that could be in hillsborough
here
so i would i would have to look at this
chart and compare it to the chart that
we use for the distribution i don't
think i'm not sure i have one of those
with me
um
i could certainly get that to the to the
committee fine uh we'll be having a work
session next wednesday okay
um and i can i could certainly provide
that ahead of time um which shows uh so
it shows that my chart that shows the
population of each county based in the
2010 census
and then it shows the populations of
those subdivisions
that had filed these lawsuits and it
deducts that and so then you get two
figures you get the the the starting
figure the for the population of
hillsborough county and then you deduct
manchester and nashua's population and
then you get the the population figure
for the remaining part of
of of hillsborough that is used for the
distribution formula okay which which
seems reasonable
i would mr chair
so
i guess we have to
check the numbers uh with these new
numbers to make sure that that's the
case
but that's your position though that yes
we shouldn't double count right so the
existing statute actually says
that the population of any political
subdivision that receives funds under
the section shall not be included in the
population of the county for determining
the distribution of that county that was
put in precisely to avoid the unfairness
of double counting
thank you
represent
tucker yes i uh live in coast county
and i'm
have
been concerned like all representatives
have been
about the opioid crisis not only in
coast but in grafton
and we have a major problem of not
having any detox
facility in colas county
and the one that was supposed to have
one in grafton
uh
in the central part of the state
doesn't either
so
are these monies you talk about programs
but without detox
someone who has reached the decision
that they're ready for treatment
can't get into any of those programs
so i'd like really to hear that address
does this include money for detox
so that someone who believes they're
ready for help
can
qualify or are you
doing detox in the jails by just not
having the drugs available
so
if there were proposals for treatment
facilities in different parts of the
state that doesn't have a lot of
treatment facilities and cross county is
one sullivan county is another part of
the state that doesn't
and there were proposals to have
treatment centers
so
in in looking at the the treatment the
long-term treatment of opioid use
disorder patients
so detox is a very small part of it but
but it's key but i'm not well it's it's
it's it's key to a certain point and i'm
not sure that you need residential
treatment the science seems to indicate
that a lot of this treatment can happen
at home in uh in certain situations the
most effective treatment for opioid use
disorder is is medical assistance
treatment drugs
like suboxone
it's proven that because of the nature
of an opioid addiction which is not the
same as other kinds of addictions
because it changes brain chemistry
so opioids do something different to the
person and the the addiction that is
created is overwhelmingly powerful i was
a public defender for 14 years i dealt
with many many clients who were addicted
to opiates
many clients and i would talk to them
about
what is this addiction like and they
would describe this craving that never
goes away
and that is so powerful which is why
oftentimes an opioid
treatment
relapse is such an important part of it
because it it happens a lot that craving
never goes away one of the most
effective ways of doing it is through
drugs like suboxone
um
and
it's so it's not just a matter of
putting him into a a treatment facility
without oftentimes without this a system
this this this medical assisted
treatment
um it's not going to be successful so
that's the sort of stuff that we need to
make sure we're providing access to
to everyone in the state and so in some
cases
there may be a need for
transportation services for people who
are having a hard time getting to a
nearby uh uh treatment facility
and the current the current statute
would provide that as an appropriate use
of these funds
um you know we so and just in terms of
this
of where this is
this opioid abatement commission which
is a wide-ranging commission made of of
state uh local county
uh treatment uh providers uh it's a
broad range commission um
we we've successfully
uh approved rules we did that a few
months ago um we're now waiting for
gelca to act it's scheduled i think for
the next month or so
yes that has delayed uh this this
putting out the money but um but as
initial as an initial figure out how
how you can
actually
fairly distribute the money and the
statute
would would uh require that so we've
done it we've we've put together rules
they've been approved by the commission
they have been they've been uh sent to
gel cow we're hoping that we get uh
that approved so that we can distribute
this money once those rules are approved
my expectation is that this money as it
comes in
will be going out on a really a fairly
frequent basis the rules actually say
that when there's there's at least 500
000 in that trust fund that we need to
invite grant applications so we can
start getting that money sent out and so
we have 2.3 million i mean frankly it's
a it's you know somewhat of a
frustration that hasn't been able to go
out before but we have to work within
the structure of law and structure of
government and this is how we we do
things things in an organized way so the
expectation is that as we get money and
we're going to get money at least for
the next 18 years
if this settlement that we're about to
to finalize with the three major
distributors gets approved then we
should be able to turn this money around
quickly and it would be available to
to any political subdivision in the
state not just to those 23 political
subdivisions who happened to hire
contingency fee council
uh and and filed a lawsuit
and and and i can let me say this again
i mean
now there's a there's a there's a a
question of profound fairness here right
these 23 subdivisions are now saying
that they are entitled to
uh extra consideration for this money up
to 40 percent of the money
uh because they were litigating
subdivisions that's the that's the whole
justification in the law they were
litigating subdivisions
they never litigated anything
never and so there is no dispute there's
no factual dispute that they never
litigated anything they filed complaints
that went into federal court in
cleveland ohio those complaints have
been was stayed
nothing happened to them there was no
litigation whatsoever
so how do you say that that justifies
them getting 40 percent
to the exclusion of the other political
subdivisions in the state
that that didn't which includes you know
hudson and merrimack and bedford and and
and durham and all of these towns that
also have their own
opioid problems everyone every political
subdivision should have an equal say now
we agreed to give 15 percent to those
litigating subdivisions as a compromise
but to increase it to 40 percent or more
i just think there's a there's a
question of fundamental fairness
and which is why we've opposed the bill
um thank you very much
we can get into more details in the work
session
if we get
what i
really want to do is
what is the kind of information there
what
other information do we need
yes representative
michaelis
yes uh most of you don't know me my name
is rich lasallis i represent the town of
litchfield in hillsborough county and
just to follow up on representative
tucker's
question
it's my understanding that
this this spreadsheet is very heavily
weighted toward population numbers
it's my understanding that the impact of
opioids
is
not
evenly divided uh
across the state based upon population
that the actual
prescriptions
that were applied
are heavily weighted toward rural areas
which would certainly include
colossal county and some of the other
rural areas
and the reason for that was that those
areas did not have
the availability
of other
less
opioid heavily weighted
pain
they didn't have what for instance
physical therapy available to them so
opioids was prescribed
more heavily than perhaps someone in
my county of hillsborough county that's
why for instance the state of west
virginia
which is a very rural
state as a whole
has a tremendous opioid problem
so i would and i don't anticipate being
back here on the committee but i would
ask that the committee members
take that into consideration and any
time that
that
monies are being divided out
to keep in mind that
sullivan county and grafton current
county in colossae county
the impact of opioids
is
is more
horrendous in those counties
way beyond what a population chart would
seem to suggest
so thank you for for uh
that
anybody else
represented
morphy
thank you mr chairman my question and i
appreciate your passion about
the fairness of the distribution of
these monies which i think is critically
important because
from a clinical perspective there is a
lot of
opioid addiction that is not even we are
not aware of
so because you filed a suit does not
mean that you have a greater proportion
of people addicted so my question to you
in preparation for next week do you have
available to you a breakdown
geographically through the state of the
numbers of cases of patients or people
involved with opioid addiction
because it goes beyond just the
population numbers that you're referring
to it also goes to specifically getting
the dollars to those that deserve it and
need it and so it would be helpful for
us to understand
exactly the distribution throughout the
state beyond 23 entities
thank you for your question
representative i i
let me talk to uh to somebody at dhhs
and they have folks that are doing that
i don't know how much of that is
reported so that the state would have
access to the number of patients who are
reporting substance use but they may
have some sort of geographical data
that
may be helpful
um
but but so but that's exactly why this
the current system which has not even
yet been been put into place
that's why it's so effective because it
precisely because it it it can it allows
us to address the needs in other s
sections of the state that are not
affected by population and so that the
commission can say well you know there
are problems in sullivan county
that that need to be addressed
their needs uh because of lack of of
treatment resources for instance may be
greater we need to take that into
consideration even though it's a smaller
county we need to take that into
consideration and it allows the
commission to direct the funds in in
ways that it's going to have the most
effect for for the people of new
hampshire to address the opioid crisis
follow mr
follow
i would appreciate that because i have
asked the hospital association because
they really don't have the ability to
dig down deep into where all the
patients come from in their catchment
area it would be helpful if dhhs had
some more accurate um
numbers about the distribution or the
the spread or the where these patients
or where these people are i i will
certainly ask uh thank you provide
whatever i can
thank you
for other questions
representing
this very brief
sequel to that on they may have numbers
only by hospital and
my hospital will be seeing people over a
wide area so that would not be helpful
thanks representative romney so we're
talking about rsa
we're talking about rsa 126
uh a
con 84.
so what i just want to make sure i
understand
this is what created
this commission
it's it's actually 80 sections 83 to 86.
okay but yeah three six okay
uh follow up
miss chair
so
in that original statute
was was there any formula prescribed or
the formula was supposed to be
prescribed by the
the commission no it's so it's an
actually the formula is in 126 a 83
section 2 which has the formula um
about how the 15
would be distributed to those litigating
subdivisions uh and it mentions the 2020
the 2010 census and it has that language
i talked about about not double counting
so in the chart that we were handed that
would be the
mckinsey settlement
first are we just talking about mckinsey
settlement or going forward other
settlements so this would apply to all
settlements that came in mckinsey is the
first
uh and only at this point settlement of
opioid funds that the states receive so
there was that 15 distribution that that
my office made to those
litigating subdivisions under the
statute and then the remaining money
um is in the opioid uh abatement trust
fund so but there will be
uh there will be
uh settlement funds i predict coming in
for at least 18 years over different
periods of the time over over those
years uh and you know upwards of
150 or so million dollars that will come
into the state that will be used and has
to be used for opioid abatement purposes
okay and mr chair so that so then
that 15
would apply to those counties or
or towns or cities that signed on to any
other future litigation
yes it would yeah and yeah so and they
didn't sign on to anything what they did
was they they agreed to hire contingency
fee council national contingency fee
council who filed on their behalf
lawsuits
all those lawsuits went to federal court
and were consolidated in the federal
court in cleveland so they haven't
signed anything they just hired
national council to to file these
lawsuits on their behalf okay and this
one more this is real final so what's
before us
is a bill that wants to for the mckinsey
settlement
push nope for all sediments push it
above the 15 percent yeah so uh that so
that the the the
mckinsey money was already distributed
under this current formula so any
any settlements any any settlements to
come into any entity in the state any
to the state itself to any city town
county has to go into the opioid trust
fund before that
then a certain percentage would be given
to the litigating subdivisions
and so essentially
the bill in front of you would say we're
gonna we're gonna change it from 15
to i think i have to look at the latest
draft of 40
of that would go to those just to those
subdivisions and hired outside counsel
to represent them okay
no i'm clear thank you thank you
anybody else
if not uh
this will even make it more juicier come
wednesday can i ask what what what time
is is your work session it starts at 9
30. okay and
okay
we may not go in numerical order okay
she put nine
then nine o'clock
all right um that closes the
work session on all the all of our bills
this is all confusing no that's good
you